حسنًا ، حقيقة أنه لم يُسمح لنا ولا
لوسائل الإعلام الروسية بالتقاط
صورة للاجتماع بين
الرئيس ترامب ووزير الخارجية الروسي
سيرغي لافروف ، مما يؤكد
مدى حساسية هذه المواجهة على
وجه الخصوص في وقت
يواجه فيه الرئيس ترامب عملية عزل
لكنه يحجب الجيش.  المساعدات من
أوكرانيا ، وهي دولة
غزت روسيا جزئيًا في مؤتمر صحفي بعد
الاجتماع ، تحدث وزير الخارجية لافروف عن
مجموعة من القضايا
التي ناقشها هو والرئيس الأمريكي بشأن الحد من
التسلح ، والصراعات في سوريا ، وأوكرانيا
وأفغانستان ، والوضع مع
الاتفاق النووي الإيراني.  والتعاون الاقتصادي
بين الولايات
المتحدة وروسيا ، لم يعطِ إجابة واضحة ،
ولكن عندما سئل مرارًا عما إذا كان
الرئيس ترامب وحذر روسيا من
التدخل في الانتخابات الأمريكية ،
أصر البيت الأبيض على أن الرئيس ترامب أصدر
مثل هذا التحذير عندما تم الضغط عليه بشأن القضية التي
اعترف بها لافروف.  الذي
تحدثه وزير الخارجية الأمريكي مايك بومبيو
في هذا الصدد ، لكنه لم
يشر إلى الرئيس ترامب جيدًا ،
كان هذا أول اجتماع رسمي في
المكتب البيضاوي بين ترامب ولافروف
منذ مايو 2017 عندما يُزعم أن ترامب
ناقش
معلومات استخباراتية سرية للغاية مع وزير الخارجية
الروسي والسفير الروسي آنذاك
لافروف أيضًا.  أكد دعوة
ترامب لحضور احتفالات يوم النصر
في موسكو العام المقبل لكنه قال إن
الرئيس الأمريكي لم يقرر بعد
ما إذا كان سيأتي أم لا.